hello my name is Shivani Suki and I'll
be talking about functions singularities
and their applications so in Mathematica
11 we have built-in knowledge about
singularities and branch cuts of special
of mathematical functions
so basically previous versions of
Mathematica of course needed this
knowledge and various functions had
their own impartial implementation of
the things so so many function is to
answer a question like is the input a
continuous function or where the
discontinuities of the input or is the
input an analytic function so but here
with Mathematica 11 we have unified the
knowledge so that it's in one place and
all the functions accessing it from the
same place place and we sort of try to
make it as complete as we can so it's at
least as complete as functions that
Wolfram comm knowledge so here it is so
what kind of information do we store so
is the function locally analytic meaning
analytic in some neighborhood of the
point what is the location of branch
cuts of the function what is the
location of definition boundaries so
that would be boundaries of the domain
of the function boundaries of the set of
real arguments for with which the
function is real valued so if we are
looking the real domain of the function
so where the function becomes not real
and boundaries of piecewise cases if
this is a piecewise function another
information location of poles essential
singularities and branch points for for
some functions it's important that we
distinguish between those for others
it's not so so this general knowledge
base does make a distinction so we will
describe the singularity or currently
the
so one thing I an international
dysfunction is not yet packaged as user
function so so as you can see here it's
simplified context function that that
gives not quite completely designed
output but it's it's what's used
internally and in the in the next
version we will have better package
design system context function for this
so I'll describe what we have right now
so what we what we keep in in the
knowledge base is description of
singularities as pairs equation and
condition so that the solution set of
equation and condition includes the
singularity set it may be strict
inclusion so so basically we we do not
have information about exact location of
singularities we may have to give a
larger set that's that's because we want
to propagate the description through
function composition and the exact
location of singularities may not
propagate since for instance poles from
from different parts of the expression
may cancel or branch cuts may cancel or
through a composition a pole may become
an essential singularity or may not and
we don't we don't have this detailed
information because we want to collect
this information very fast so we are not
really computing kind of thing we are
collecting information syntactically and
basically propagating it true through
this formula simple formula it's so
singularity of a composition of function
f ways with an argument function is will
be singularity of F with variables
replaced by those functions plus
singularities of of the argument
functions that means we can really fast
collect this information just by knowing
the information about every named
building function
so as I said here polls might become
essential singularities or removable
singularities of the composed function
so function singularities would assume
worst-case-scenario meaning that if we
say that that there may be an essential
singularity it means there is an
essential singularity or a pole or
removable singularity and if we say
there is a pole then it means there may
be a follower there may be a removable
singularity there but we always give a
set which includes all singularities so
here's the the current output of this
function basically you get list of
description of branch cuts domain
boundaries this comes from the
elliptical inversely become Q then this
will be poles essential singularities
and branch points so what what are the
current application of it applications
for instance those are applied in
visualization there will be two
visualization talks after my talk
they're probably more about it so we for
instance with Mathematica 10 plot didn't
know about the similarities of tangent
and that's why we were getting these
vertical lines now it does have the
information and there are no vertical
lines so the plot looks much nicer same
for gamma functions again we had
vertical lines for singularities and in
automatically when the run lines are
gone here's a function composition so
you can see that the old version again
had vertical lines the new version can
figure out the singularities of a
function composition and we got nicer
picture yes
oh I typed in manually evaluator goes to
named Colonel in those cells that do
that use the mathematical even and
here's a tree picture so again there was
a singularity here and and we sort of
got got this wall here and if plot 3d
now sub where the singularities are we
got much nicer picture okay so now
solving univariate transcendental
equation other quite different area that
also needed the information about
function singularity and it did have
some information before but what it was
not as complete as it is now so reduced
and related function find the roots of
univariate holomorphic function in a
complex rectangle using the following
heuristics we we first find begin
approximation of the roots using
numerical method then we use interval
arithmetic for ailment airy functions or
significance arthritic for non
elementary functions because we don't
have interval arithmetic for those and
the criterion based on ohshit erm to
prove the existence of multiplicities of
roots so so then we have we have proven
that the roots are where we found them
were where the numerical method has
found them and then we need to prove
that we have found all the roots the
numerical method might of or might not
have found all the roots so to do this
we need to compute the by winding number
of the function along the boundary of
the rectangle and this way we will know
how many roots counted with
multiplicities are inside and if this
number agrees with the number of roots
that we have found we know that we have
solved the problem so
but of course to to do this we first
need to know that the function is called
a morphic in the rectangle so that's
that's where the singularity information
enters and so for instance here there is
a column or fig function and we get the
solution we got a warning since well the
warning means exactly what it says solve
needed to use numeric integration to to
compute the winding number so we can
compute the winding number using
interval arithmetic for elementary
functions for non elementary functions
we need to use numeric integration but
it's so it's almost proven that we have
the correct number of solutions it's
really unlikely that numeric integration
didn't give the first digit correct
because we needs to tell between five
and four ends or six roots here so and
here's a picture we can see that we have
found all the five roots these are zeros
or imaginary part so were the intersect
are the roads now a meromorphic
functions that is this is something
that's new in version 11 so version
version 10 and the earlier had some
knowledge about where the function is
holomorphic so for some holomorphic
functions it will work we didn't have
any information for meromorphic function
location of poles so so that wouldn't
work in version 10 so we have a function
that's meromorphic and we can find the
roots of it now there are no messages
because this was an elementary function
so the additional information that we
need for meromorphic function is the
location of roots so we get equations of
poles we get equations where that need
to be satisfied by the poles we solve
the equation with equations then we
compute the multiplicity of the pole at
the solution and
this way and knowing the winding number
we can compute the number of roads
here's a picture okay
this are these four routes our
intersection points at intersection
points are roads and this you can see
that it's not quite intersecting there
is a little fast here because that's
that's that's the pole that's that's
where the real part goes off to infinity
so there isn't three intersection in
these two points and here's what it
looks like if we plot the absolute value
of the function you can see that it has
two poles here and the roots are sort of
underneath here so the the minima of the
absolute absolute value root counting so
that's pretty much the same the same as
finding clues except we don't really
need to find the roots we just need to
count them so we need to compute the
winding we need to compute the winding
number and we need to know that the
function is holomorphic or that is a
meromorphic function and we need to then
locate the the poles and and find the
pole multiplicity then we can we can
counter roots so here's an example and
lemon teri function takes a while to
count the roots because that that's with
this exponential term and cubic cubed
term in inside the tangent it will have
many roots yes
yes III and I do have a winding number
functioning in the internal context
which you might explore it's correct or
not so so do the winding hammer function
if if it's an elementary function if it
uses the interval arithmetic and and we
also have complex interval arithmetic
also in immigrant context and here's a
here's a picture so this function has
has a lot of spikes those spikes or
poles that we have we need to count the
the poles come from from the tangent
function and the the roots are the
spikes I underneath so there should be
71 of them I don't know if the numerical
method got over here and here is a
special function so this was really fast
the numeric integration here and we we
see that our eleven roots and where the
Adama roots are and intersection but
it's root counting so they didn't mark
their roots because we haven't found
them just counted 37 of them and
periodic function so count roots you
uses function periods so that's that's
another function that we had for a few
versions now that can find data on a
periodicity of a given function so if we
recognize that the function is periodic
then we read to count the roots in one
period and in the remainder of the
period so we didn't really have to sort
of count winding number of six billion
here we just need to count it in one one
period on to count the number of periods
and the count the remainder sort of
modulo pi off of this the length of this
interval
and here's this is something that
actually take a while because evaluation
of Jacobi CD is not that fast so but in
69 seconds we can compute there is three
I think quintillion of roads in in this
rectangle so okay univariate
optimization other area where we need
data on function singularities so if we
want to optimize a univariate function
for which we can symbolically compute
derivative we not only need to find the
roots of the derivative but the
derivative is computed in generic sense
meaning that it may have discontinuities
and we we need to find those discrete
discontinuities and also the function
may may not be always real valued so we
we need to find the endpoints of the
real valued nas domain of the function
so here's the first example we'll have a
maximum at a regular point of a function
so you can see I constructed the
function which with a bit with a
function component that's a piecewise
function so it's not not function that
would always have derivative and here's
the solution in terms of its object it's
an exact number and here here's the plot
of the function you can see the function
have was at the few discontinuities and
here the derivative had discontinuity
but the maximum happens to be at at the
0 of the derivative but if we slightly
change the function so you look at the
function here I just added other the
constant there multiplied the first term
by constant
we compute the maximum here that now the
maximum is at zero and and that's the
point where derivative is discontinued
this continues where the maximum occurs
here's another example so this function
looks sort of looks analytic but you
will see on the plot that it's not quite
the case because of the arc cosine which
which has branch points where sine is 1
and minus 1 so that's what the function
looks like and the maximum is actually
at one of those points where the
derivative is discontinuous and again
the same function which which with
constant changed ok I added the constant
2 here and this is to illustrate that
that we also need to know where the end
points of the real valued nest domains
are we get a solution and the solution
happens to be at the end point of
revivalist domain the function is not
really valued between those species of
the graph limit computation so this is
sort of trivial criterion the fusion
function is continuous at seed and and
the limit of the function at Point C is
equal to the value but before we had the
information about where the function is
continuous limit was not using this
information because it didn't have it so
it was computing serious of of whatever
function we it got and if if the
function is complicated that the
computation of serious takes a long time
for instance if we take nested cosine to
it 17 times then computation of limit of
this at zero takes 119,000 seconds in
in version 11 actually because this is
something that was implemented after
virtual even so this is will come in the
next version so and after the criterion
cosines of course continuous at 0 so so
we get like 0.3 millisecond for the same
thing which is that the highest measured
speed up that I was able to ever do 3.9
billion well I try to let it run for a
week didn't finish sir and with function
singularities we can go to about 20,000
it's still fast so the limit here is not
not the speed limitation here the
limitation is the the stack size after
after about 100 the stock stock crashes
and that's the and we cannot replace so
the problem is replacing X with 0 in the
function use ik replace all because it
builds to card stock and and it crashes
and here is so if we if we nested
million times we still pretty quickly
figure out that the function is
continuous next example so what about if
if there are any continued any
singularities so we use tangent in
instead of cosine so so as you can see I
needed somewhat smaller number of
nesting and now it takes measurables
like time it takes one second to to
compute 400 times nested tangent and the
limitation here again why we cannot do
too much more is the evaluation of
numerical evaluation of the conditions
so that we really we produce a bunch of
conditions here you can see the leaf
council for instance if we nest tangent
10,000 times we we get
a lot of condition 10,000 conditions
they become larger and larger the leaf
count of the condition is 50 million and
replacing values in those conditions
takes time and here is an example of
sort of random composition of special
functions if I type it randomly then
it's very likely the point will be a
point of continuity and and we can get
limit really fast and that's now it's
about evaluates version 11 so so it
doesn't have the criterion for for
continuity and it took three seconds to
compute the same thing okay so let me
finish with something which I don't even
have in a development version so what
what it it's something that also can can
make use of function singularities
computing various types of integrals
using the the antiderivative so we can
compute the regular Riemann integral
using Newton life it's grm to do this we
need to find all the singularities that
are along the integration path and
compute limits at the singularities also
if we want to compute Cauchy principal
value integral again we need the
singularities along the integration part
and now we compute symmetrical limits so
it's also combination of computing
singularities and computed limits and of
course computing the antiderivative and
for Hadamard finite part integrals we
need to compute serious around
singularities and remove the non
convergent terms so again that's that's
where functional singularities will be
used there is there is some more
difficulty to do it especially if there
are symbolic parameters present we to
figure out under which conditions and
symbolic parameters which singularities
are in the integration path so that's so
solving somewhat difficult geometric
problem there but but it's something
that will use the knowledge of function
CPR it is in particular so this is all I
had
thank you
[Applause]